do you think
you can build resilience or are you born
with it
a hundred percent think you can build it
I look at my life I've had some tough
challenges this is another thing that I
really love all my tough challenges I've
never changed them yeah you hear that a
lot so when you're having a tough
challenge yeah it's difficult to see
going through it but just remember if
you never change the other ones this is
building you so I believe that
resilience is is a thought in your mind
about of how you go about it it's a
thought about Not Giving in it's not
about moving forward it's a talk about
even when things are against you you
still show up you still get on with it